this podcast is brought to you by raycon
earbuds my friends raycon everyday
earbuds look feel and sound better than
ever when I go jogging if I'm boxing or
if I'm just in the library just kidding
who goes to libraries if I'm outside uh
chilling at a Coffee Spot uh I usually
just have my air raycon earbuds on me
because they last super long and they're
super light and they're comfortable so
uh to get your raycon my friends check
this out go to buy raycon.com brain
today to get 15 off your raycon order
that's by raycon.com brain to get 15 off
that's by raycon.com brain
so once those boxes are checked for me I
have to move on and do something else
people who have been on this channel
understand that
I have gone through so many different
phases
um that was the YouTube phase the acting
phase there was the hosting phase
there's the food phase and now I'm in my
serial entrepreneurial neural phase I
can and I'll always go back to YouTube
YouTube is something that I'll never
leave because it was something that
allows me to create things without red
tape and I've said this multiple times
before I love this platform because I
don't have to ask somebody to create
something I just have to create it
whether it's good or bad in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast if you are watching this
on video I apologize crazy so before we
left oh here's the dog
can you see her that's fine whatever but
if you're watching this on video right
now we are obviously not in the studio
we're actually at Barton Geo's place if
you guys don't know who Barton Geo is
Barton Geo are really good friends of
ours in the YouTube space because uh
some of you apparently um
found this podcast through like just
regular podcast [ __ ] so uh
I've been trying to upload this video
that I shot with my buddy soosh it's a
interview slash musician type of thing
ugh I don't know uploaded it three times
and it didn't [ __ ] work so now we're
back here
doing a makeshift one because we have
some ads that we have to read well
really you're going to mention that yes
honestly I'm honest about everything
Mary come to the rescue for a last
minute podcast about myself you could
with that attitude you can't help your
husband out without throwing a little
salt in the wounds how is that so I said
Mario come to the rescue that's a ticket
you know he's just saying he's been
using this word called that I've been
saying to him he doesn't even know what
it means and he just uses it for
everything I say because it makes her
bad it like makes no sense so explain to
people what uh explain people what
uh it's Korean word and you use it
people who hold grudges
that's what it is to see you no and then
like they won't let it go so David I
forget what the example was but
basically I said sorry I did something
else I apologize he would not let it go
and I was like God you're such you have
such teeth good and he's like what does
that mean I'm like oh let me tell you
what this girl
whatever that doesn't make it
was thank
you I wasn't saying anything bad I was
like America let me let me tell you this
right now everything doesn't end guys
let me let me tell you this a few years
in and we're still Victory let me tell
you something okay
let me tell you the most deceptive thing
this girl ever did this is this is some
this is this is
this means for divorce all right so
we're in the room you really know let's
not talk about that I'm about to have a
new draw here I can't have it why just
in case someone listens who's under me
this is okay no it's okay it's okay it's
okay
it's a little bit too versatile what's
so personal about this
this is funny like this is not something
you would do in front of your parents in
front of them of course we would and
parents-in-law no yeah no you don't
think I want to tell the story no you
wouldn't do the action though you know
what I mean are we talking about the
same story right now in the bedroom
right yeah
no no maybe another time would you say
when you say better now they're gonna
think it's a completely different type
of thing
David
[Laughter]
this was it's not what anybody thinks
it's not what you think but it's very
it's deception of her no it's not it's
how you s how you imagined it how you
connected the dots which so is very
different we're about to go to sleep
right
I walk outside the door to fart and I
let one rip right
[Applause]
and then the moment I fart she goes oh
what's that smell and I paused and I'm
like hold on a second
how would you smell it if I literally
just farted and you said it at the same
time that doesn't make any sense and
then she stops and she goes oh wait it's
me
hold on okay I was very upset because
yeah she tried a Gaslight fart like me
she went but what's the point about what
would I gain out of that because you try
to make me feel like I was the
disgusting fart one when it was you you
farted no it's both of us because you
did fart that's the fact yeah but how do
you spell a fart that literally came
right out exactly which is why your
story doesn't make sense it doesn't
really happen on my end is that I was
preoccupied with my phone doing
something and then David was in the room
but he left the room which I didn't even
start like a gentleman yeah he went to
go with two he wanted he went outside
too far which I wasn't even aware of
because I was so preoccupied with my
phone and the next thing I know I smell
something I'm like oh what does that
smell so I turned around and he's there
in front of the door he's like I just
farted there's no one looked at me like
she was disgusted yeah because the smell
was disgusting and then he looked at me
he's like I just farted there's no way
you could smell it and then I connected
to dots I tracked that I'm like okay I
think I might have farted and I just
didn't recognize it because I didn't
hear anything and it was my smell and so
I was like oh I think it's mine and I
admitted it it wasn't like I was driving
so I said oh I'm so sorry and I was
cracking up because we were having two
different stories in our head I have
never felt so betrayed let it go because
till the next morning he was like you're
such a liar I can't believe I said I
apologize you let it go you did good men
you were caught fart handed dude I've
never so there it is the bedroom was
about fun
sound like it was something about sex
and it was I'm like wait it's not you
know we can't talk about it it's in the
bedroom I'm like it wasn't well you
asked you're like are we talking about
the same thing I was like the bedroom
that's the only one yeah if I say fart
then they know what the story is about
but it's fine there it is I hyped it up
[Music]
Let It Go man it's the New Year people
and um this [ __ ] went by so damn fast
um it did crazy crazy fast and like I
feel like every
it's funny like when you're younger and
you're in high school
or even like in junior high like I
remember every day feeling so slow that
I couldn't wait for the day to end and
now
the moment I wake up I blink and then
it's nighttime every day goes by so damn
quick like this year I don't even
remember what I did this year I was
gonna ask you how do you feel about this
year
you always do New Year's resolution
right I mean
I mean yeah we got this well it was the
store I mean if you guys want to know
like I mean Joe's been talking about it
on his you know on his videos but
opening up the store in Hawaii was a
[ __ ] disaster like it was so hard and
not even so much for me because Joe is
the one mainly dealing with the
operations side
um but
to tell you the the amount of pain and
struggle it took to open that store we
were supposed to open that store last a
year ago so you know for us it was like
we were just bleeding money the whole
time and I think for me if you guys I
mean you guys already know like I didn't
grow up with a lot of money so for me
ever since I started YouTube I've always
had like a the moment I started
um becoming financially stable I never
had my money go below a certain point
because I'm always scared like you don't
the the biggest difference is like when
you own a business or even when you're
in entertainment you don't know when
your next paycheck is technically coming
right and I was never a a clout chasing
YouTuber I never really sold like snake
oil stuff so I didn't stack my money
like other people there I made good
money right but I invested my money into
a lot of things for example secret
society the the June B franchise well
all that money that I saved up I threw
into the store in Hawaii so which was
kind of uh scary because the original
investment that I was supposed to put in
wasn't the amount that it ended up being
and none of us could account for that
because of all the [ __ ] that
happened in Hawaii with like
um government scandals and everything
else so it kind of pushed everything a
year back so just to give you guys like
an example not going to give you the
exact number but the amount of money
that I put in was uh half the amount
that I put in towards at the end so that
other half was supposed to be my cushion
I lost all that cushion I have never had
my account damn near close to zero
before in the last 10 years so it was a
very very scary idea for me it's not the
fact that I couldn't make money or I
wasn't going to make money but the when
you kind of grew up in uh with like a
scarcity mentality of like thinking that
you're not you don't know where your
next paycheck is going to come from you
don't know if you could pay your bills
when that thought came back into my head
I felt like I was like 18 years old all
over again and that was very
uncomfortable for me especially because
we're married now right and I know we
don't have a kid yet but the idea of not
being able to like support myself or
have money for emergencies bothers me
right or like let's say my parents
needed money I don't have the money to
give them anymore that was how much
cushion I had and all of that [ __ ]
disappeared so the last I say I mean
most of you guys don't know this just
because we're doing you know podcast
stuff and you know this is a comedy
podcast and I don't really care to tell
people about my personal issues that I'm
going through unless I've resolved it
and I have something to offer after like
as I'm solving things and I'm figuring
things out I don't want to hear [ __ ]
from other people right I want to be
able to you know talk to my community
and figure what I have to do when it
comes to
um
resolving these issues before I go ahead
and talk about it openly yeah so there's
none of this was resolved so because it
wasn't resolved I didn't want to talk
about on the podcast because that's just
me complaining to people yeah and I
don't want to complain I hate [ __ ]
complaining unless the complaint ends
with the joke
so did you have a resolution
what do you how did you resolve it or
like how are you coping well the store
opened that's how it was financially
like how are you coping that side of it
there is nothing to cope now the store
is open so I don't feel that so bad oh
really yeah that's how Okay because if
I'm just bleeding money every [ __ ]
month it's it's crazy especially because
you're not seeing any profit come out of
the end right so like I was bleeding I
was bleeding more money than I was
making which doesn't happen how is that
now
well now it's the store's running so now
I don't have to put so much money into
the store and we still have like some
back bills that we have to pay obviously
because of uh the extra construction
that we had to do but now that the
store's going up in Waikiki it's going
pretty well
um but you know that's the risk that a
lot of people don't want to take that I
think that a lot of people with the
entrepreneur mind
um we understand those risks it's like
big risk big reward right
um which is not for everybody and that's
what I figured out too because uh when I
went back home to Sacramento
um I was telling people like you know my
close friends about what's going on and
because I think from the outside
perspective everybody thinks I'm balling
right that I'm that I'm this highly
successful person and you know which I
am successful but not to the extent that
they think that I am so when they go oh
like you'll talk to some friends and
they go oh the rich guy is coming
through I'm like in what sense am I rich
I'm like I've invested all my like I
told them I told I had a conversation
with a friend back home I was like I
guarantee you if I open my bank account
right now you'll be surprised how little
money I have in it compared to you right
and what I was telling him is that you
and I gamble differently
you want to wake up every day to a nine
to five make sure that there's a safe
paycheck in there and then you have your
fun outside of your job which is really
[ __ ] dope for me
I make risks and I gamble all the time
so in terms of what I have in the bank
account is not very much I guarantee you
have way more money in your account than
I do so it's just a different type of
Lifestyle so I'd probably say about like
80 percent of the money I've made I
invested into all these businesses in
the last like four or five years
my lovely genius brain listeners the new
year is almost here my friends and
whether you're making big changes or
just settling back into a consistent
routine chances are you could use some
audio accompaniment on your journey and
that's right I'm talking about doing
that with raycon ear buds my friends
raycon everyday earbuds look feeling
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips and the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge trust me and the
best thing about them that I love about
them eight hours of play time in a 32
hour battery life raycons are priced
just right you get quality audio at half
the price of other premium Brands my
friends we got customized sound profiles
earbud tap functions noise isolation
awareness mode and so much more I like
mine because they're super light a lot
of earbuds that I get are very very
heavy and they promise a lot for their
price tag and I don't I don't know I
prefer the raycons because look I can't
feel them in my here I go jogging with
them I box with them when I hit the bag
I go biking with them and I'll be honest
with you I love them go to buy
raycon.com brain today to get 50 off
your raycon order that's by raycon.com
brain to get 15 off that's by raycon.com
brain
you remember you're saying you were
saying that you like to be in chaotic
situation this is too much chaos though
because there was a little too much
chaos it was a little more than I could
handle well that's why you and I are
kind of different very different polar
opposite in that situation because I'm
someone who likes to be in the safe Zone
nine to six having paycheck come every
weekly bi-weekly whatever and have the
safe money come in I I don't know if I
have like you you have the personality
to
kind of Gamble and risk that situation
and maybe it's a good thing that we
don't have the same type of personality
in that sense because
I like to have my safe income
yeah I mean
I play it relatively safe compared to I
think a lot of other serial
entrepreneurs and a lot of my motivation
comes from like reading things about
other people who are highly successful
and reading about how many times they
fail like you know people like Walt
Disney
like the amount of times that man has
failed before he struck gold once is
kind of ridiculous it's like I I can't
remember I read it years years ago
um when I was looking for like
inspiration but you probably failed like
I don't know like 60 something times
multiple businesses multiple ideas and
then he created this Empire and
that's the thing that kind of motivates
me because I can go throughout life and
just Coast
coasting is not a problem I think most
people enjoy that
um and what I mean by coasting is that
I'm not saying that you're sitting there
and just wasting your life away that's
not what I mean at all I'm saying that
you there's like a steady route that
people can take and they can enjoy and
love life the way that they do I want to
create something that's going to leave a
lasting impact I I did it in you know
like the Asian American sense of
entertainment when YouTube first started
that box is checked so for me
you know
people are like how come you didn't want
to reach towards the uh the 2 million or
three play more why there's it does
nothing for me the moment the moment I
hit 500 000 subscribers nothing mattered
anymore why because I prove that I could
do this like 500. I think 500 was just a
mark for me I was like oh I got 500 then
it became a million and then it'll
almost hit two mil when it hit when I
hit that million mark it didn't do
anything for me I didn't feel good it
didn't feel like a piece of
accomplishment it's just like oh it's
just more subscribers
that's all that it felt so once those
boxes are checked for me I have to move
on and do something else people who have
been on this channel understand that
I have gone through so many different
phases
um that was the YouTube phase the acting
phase there was the hosting phase
there's the food phase and now I'm in my
serial entrepreneurial neural phase I
can and I'll always go back to YouTube
YouTube is something that I'll never
leave because it was something that
allows me to create things without red
tape and I've said this multiple times
before I love this platform because I
don't have to ask somebody to create
something I just have to create it
whether it's good or bad
um and then it allows me to kind of work
out these ideas I don't
so what if I don't book another movie or
you know do something else in acting
I've already done it like two or three
times so it's like it never feels that's
that's how I knew I was different from
other actors or when actors book
something they feel excited about it not
just because of the paycheck is because
they get to put all their work into a
character that they've worked on for so
long for me
if that only happens if I really really
enjoyed the project but in my position
now Beggars can't be choosers I don't
want to be a beggar like I don't care to
like I don't care to work this you know
TV spot for a 30 second spot and they go
well this is a great opportunity I was
like for who
like I don't care if I'm on this TV show
or not for 30 seconds I don't care if my
face is on this damn show it doesn't
matter to me
does any of that perspective chain has
changed for you being from single to a
married man
I don't think so I think the biggest
change for us is going to be when we
have a kid
the other reason why I want to open a
business is because if we do have a kid
and we have a family right because I
don't know what's going to happen with
this if I delved my whole life into
entertainment you would never see me
it would be like in the beginning stages
of our relationship I was up all night
living super unhealthy
um kind of just focusing on the crap I
mean a lot of money and a lot of
opportunities came out from that but I
was pretty miserable right super
unhealthy I can never go back to being
that person again like not sleeping not
caring about my health just sitting
there in a room writing all day uh some
people enjoy that because
their end goal is for whatever the
crafter it could be craft or the
notoriety but those are the sacrifices
that you have to make everything that
I've read from people that I look up to
in terms of reaching their level of
greatness they sacrificed everything
their personal relationships their times
with spent time with their family
vacations whatever right
um and that's great for them I can't do
that I did that for too long and I I
garnered a certain amount of success but
that success wasn't worth the amount of
time that I spent not doing things that
I enjoyed and being around the people
that I care about
so those are the things that I can't get
back so
um I think I had my time with that and I
enjoy it and now I'm trying to balance
both out if I wanted to be very and I'm
saying not in a very not in a cocky way
too right and I'm learning to kind of
understand
um how to really appreciate my level of
skills without feeling like I'm like I'm
an undeserving of the things that I've
worked hard for and so when I say this
it's not that I'm being cocky it's me
understanding how hard of a worker I am
if I wanted to and I gave up everything
I said I'm going to be an actor I
guarantee you I'm snatching everybody's
[ __ ] rolls not because I'm talented I
just work that much harder than
everybody else I know for a fact
anything that I put my mind to whether
it's going to take 10 to 20 years from
now I'll get those [ __ ] things like I
don't give a [ __ ]
I I genuinely believe in terms of like
because I enjoy acting right I just
don't care about the business and
everything that comes around it if I
dedicated my life if I cut everything
out all I did was care about the craft
acting and all this other stuff I'm
snatching every [ __ ] one of your
roles out there every [ __ ] male Asian
actor Your Role I will take it right
from under you because I'm just better
than you because I guarantee you I would
work that much harder than you when
you're working 20 hours I'm working 24.
is there a time that's gonna happen no I
just don't care for it that's what I
figured out though during that acting
thing right because even early on when I
was signed to a big agency they were
shocked they're like okay we're gonna
put you out there um these these people
don't know who you are and I was getting
callbacks for major roles and they were
super excited that like you normally
normally like your first year of acting
when you go in you don't get like three
or four callbacks for these major
television shows so they were really
excited and I didn't want to do it
anymore and they got pissed at me so and
it wasn't because I was disappointed
because I didn't get the roles because
the callbacks were great it's just I
didn't care for the projects and I just
kept auditioning for things that I
thought were terrible I didn't think
what about uh like how much were they
gonna provide you was it gonna was it
gonna be working you don't you don't
know what the money is oh you don't no
you don't know what the money is you
just you're auditioning and then that
stuff comes later
so but then I did other things that I
cared about which was jubi
right so in a podcast and those things
were a lot more fulfilling
so you know like figuring my way out
this this whole past year has been very
interesting or it doesn't even feel like
you guys I would say three years because
Kobe put a halt on everything yeah
everything [ __ ] stopped so I I really
it was a good and a bad thing because
all of us got to reevaluate what was
important to us right and I found out
that though I do enjoy acting if you
send me an audition I'm going to try my
best
to get that role but if I don't get it
it doesn't affect me at all like when a
world when even when I level role and I
kill it I get like two three callbacks
and I don't get it I go okay I just move
on but I see other active friends where
it devastates them and that's because
that's how passionate they are about
their work and I don't have that I don't
have that part where I care if it's a
good and a bad thing right because I can
go on about my day and and move on and
feel okay but I think in order to be in
this acting space you have to be like
them that passion you have to have that
passion it has to hurt when you when you
put all of your life effort into a role
and you don't get it it has to hurt
that's how you'll become successful in
this because they're doing the things
that I'm saying that I could do if I
cared right so when I see my friends
like Lawrence
he booked this show on the CW as a
series regular I see his passion for
acting he can take any [ __ ] role or
script and he can make it great and
that's what makes him an amazing [ __ ]
actor and so
um when I'm in this acting space it's
only because I have opportunities
because
um I had a project that went to Sundance
and I have had these projects online
that people can see so they see that I
could fill this role
um which I'm very much grateful for but
if I don't pursue this they're not going
to keep knocking on my door so yeah
I mean that in a way that's kind of good
because then it's just less competition
for those who are out there like they're
actually working with folks who want to
keep that passion going yeah then what
is I mean do you have passion for any
other things just this business I want
this business to do well Jimmy I have to
check it off right if it's not checked
off it's gonna bother me for the rest of
it
uh do it well though it has to make
money
do you have like a certain time about
how much money no there's no certain
time it just has to be profitable like
it's profitable now but it's not enough
to like for us to live off of so unless
that happens then it's not checked off
this box has to be checked if it's not
checked I'm not moving on from it
can't do it it has to be checked off
so joombie has been going on now for
about five years so until we get to that
point where either we all decide to shut
it down or remove for it then the box is
not checked off but the business is
still going into successful I mean the
Corp the company yeah this is a bucket
list thing I want to have a very
successful franchise so because acting
will always be there entertainment will
always be there YouTube will always be
there I have no problem going back I
could do YouTube till I'm 67 years old
it doesn't matter you know
um but this part of my life is the
chapters not closed yet
um is that their last check
no I have a lot more checks there's that
I'm trying to get like buff really once
really yeah and then
um I did like the the kickboxing stuff
so that's kind of already checked
um
but this is the last last thing that uh
that hasn't that I've been working on
for a long time that hasn't been checked
off I mean we have like six open stores
and we're franchising like three three
more or something like that
um which is great but until I see like
that fat check coming from it where it
feels like financially I'm stable from
it then this is just a pipe dream and I
know like I always say like money's not
a motivation but opening a business is
money is the motivation right because if
this money comes in it allows me the
freedom to do other things that I want a
lot of things I can't do because I don't
have the fun for it so for me I decide
to gamble take all the money I saved up
throw it into this franchise uh
I don't really do New Year resolution
anymore why
I don't know I think
I could have my goals which
just because we have New Year's coming
up doesn't mean that my goals change
and I've come to realization that
I could do only so much with my goals
but I can't control what the universe
has for us right like covet comes around
you know if we had if my new resolution
is to do something that's like traveling
or like do something that
is you know interacting with people but
kovic comes around
and Lord behold like it's not it's not
just three weeks it's a year two maybe
three even and you know it could be
longer than that
it's just such a disappointment for me
like I had such high expectation and
like motivation to do something but
something like that comes around I just
I just want to be
I just want to set expectation that's
more realistic
where I don't get disappointed to my in
myself
yeah but why would you get disappointed
from a New Year's goal though
because the goal is to accomplish those
right
but if you can't do it I get
disappointed that's just who I am
um so I like to keep it more realistic
and if anything else achieve more than
what
I set myself for
um
then it's me coming around like oh I did
more than what I expected and I rather
feel that I rather feel
better about myself doing bad doing more
than what I expected than having a whole
list and not able to achieve them
yeah but New Year's goals aren't even if
you set a New Year's goal if you don't
achieve it as long as you work towards
it I kind of consider it the same thing
that's right
sometimes people don't achieve their New
Year's goals because they said there's
sites too high could be yeah it's like
this year my business is going to blow
up it's like how how do you
yeah so it's like the mindset of that
you know people are very passionate
about they're gonna I'm gonna open it
I'm gonna be successful with it it could
happen and you know if you manifest it
it could happen
um so you don't have any goals for next
year I didn't say that I do have goals
but
I think it's just it's not like a bucket
list of like this is what I'm gonna this
is what I'm gonna do because next year
it's gonna be a very different lifestyle
uh there's a lot of events happening
and
I'm just my goal is to meet what I'm
saying
sane and healthy I think that's what it
is I think the past few years during
covid mentally
it was a challenge for me just working
from home
um which is something that I realized
that I'm very not fond of I like to work
at the company meet my co-workers engage
in person
however it's not really part of my
industry anymore we all work remotely
there is hybrid but
um you know it's just not the same and
so
trying to figure out how to cope with
that and get myself together I still
feel like I'm kind of building myself to
see you know to be who I was or like be
the new me I feel like I'm still
somewhat broken so I want to make sure
I'm wholesome
um and able to overcome some of the
events that are coming around next year
I mean because you're starting a new job
yes I'm also starting a new drop I'm
really excited and also very anxious
just because it's it's a whole new
industry
um
but I think I'll be fine with that and
then I want to make sure that we could
travel as much as we can next year I
think it'll be like one of our like last
time really traveling solo you know we
kind of pushed that out and we've been
traveling with friends and family but
hopefully
we could get some like solo trips that
we've been wanting to do
um yeah
yeah I mean every every year there's
like new goals that everybody sets and I
think that uh for like the younger
people who are listening or even adults
I think when you don't achieve your
goals it's not something to look
as if you failed because you can always
just push it over to the next year as
long as you kind of progress forward
right so
I think that's why people get
disappointed in themselves a lot they
kind of set their goals so high that if
it doesn't happen they look at it as a
complete failure but you never know
what's going to happen so I I it's
always good to
I think to set things that you try to
achieve because for me it's about
incremental steps right so if somebody
just so for example let's say you do
want to go into the acting field and
you're like I'm going to book a series
regular and it doesn't happen do you
not put that goal for the next year
after or does it stop right there right
but maybe you got callbacks maybe your
acting got better maybe you filled in
like certain gaps that you could didn't
do before so you did achieve a the goal
to a certain extent it just didn't
happen in the way that you wanted it to
and you know life is long so if it
doesn't happen this year then you could
if it's still important to you then do
it again next year and get better and
better and better after that
yeah no I totally agree uh things just
um based on person that's just who I am
and based on my personality I like to
make sure that I make
um goals that are definitely achievable
I used to be someone who have a whole
list and be pretty aggressive in my
schedule but I come to realize that I'm
not that person anymore and so I need to
kind of hold step back and
be more realistic and like you said you
know take small steps and figure out how
to get that motivation or inspiration
back so that there are you know big
goals that I have at the end in my life
that I want to really be proud of like
you know having my grandma's uh
children's book you know that was
something that I had a goal years ago to
finish but
just because of you know situation in
our in our world and uh inspiration it's
been delayed and that's like one of the
things it's like such a disappointment
but I don't want
that disappointment lead to me not doing
it I was like I'm still gonna do it but
I need to figure out how to bring that
inspiration back motivation back and
that's where I need to figure out next
year too yeah
well great well guys uh that wraps up
this episode of The Genius brain podcast
is a short episode we're headed out to
Utah to go do some [ __ ] but of course uh
how to get one in because I can't miss
it most likely we're probably not going
I mean if you're watching this on the
video side we're probably not going to
do the video
um
you had a whole introduction of this
setting yeah it just doesn't look good
so it bothers me it bothers me a lot
High expectation yeah but we'll see but
uh genius print every Sundays at 12 p.m
next year we'll get it on point we're
gonna do a few changes
um but it's gonna be fun hope you guys
achieve a true achieve your New Year's
goals and uh we'll see you all in the
next year if you didn't enjoy this
episode as much as the other one my bad
it was last minute it is what it is
enjoy it either way love you guys bye
foreign
[Music]